How do you gracefully close an exceptionally bad date:
So imagine you've just finished this mediocre date
You two went to dinner and you say 'I appreciate tonight, thank you!'
Here's a hug, BUT you weren't feeling it.
You know you'll probably not gonna go for a second date.
You hug, but you keep your lips far away from each other.
Clearly you are showing this person you don't want to kiss them,
but, they still look like they are going to ask for one.
Do you wait until they realize you didn't mention wanting to hang out again?
Or that you didn't even say when you'll text or call them?
It's actually pretty confusing.
Regardless of if you are the dumpee or the dumper.
Everyone's different. Some people won't hug on the first date.
Or some people's first dates are the whole nine yards.
The current landscape of dating is filled with a bunch of landlines
and terrors.
With the life at the end of the tunnel being a shiny healthy relationship.
Getting in there is easy if you're with the right person.
But how do you keep yourself from getting  ... through that cave with the wrong person?
The person who just took you on this bad date
Well, sometimes people are like puppies: you have to cuddle them.
But still guide them with a firm grasp on the leash.
If it's a good puppy that isn't eating your shoes or homework,
give them a lot of prize and affection.
But, if it's a bad puppy who's not listening to your wants and needs,
and making fun of your waiter at the restaurant you two went to
You shouldn't hesitate to tell them:
NO! NO!
If you had a bad time, say so.
But don't accuse your date,
don't fake any interest or insult them or distroy their confidence when you look them down.
They might be in a happiness balloon and a big cloud of joy.
It needs a gently bring them back down to earth.
Instead of sending emergeless lighting ball to crash them into earth in a big ball of fire.
The great phrase to use is: I didn't feel good about tonight.
This puts the emphasis on you and how you are feeling.
Which your date will, hopefully, not take offense at.
The more you drag someone along, the more pain you're gonna call
whenever he hits the fan, for both parties involved.
If you don't decide to tell your date that in there,
'hey, I rather not see you again',
find another way to tell them directly.
Not responding and leaving them hanging in the hope that they might get the message
is a very bad idea.
Whether you need to text them, call them or send them a Snapchat,
make sure you're telling them: I don't want to keep this up.
Got any other tips to help for people who want to gracefully want to reject a bad date?
Comment below!
That's everything from us, it's time to go.
Hope you all are having a great day and feel ready to close all your future bad dates.